hey guys it is Monday and if you feel
similarly to Garfield and myself about
Mondays I've got some video game news to
cheer you up for a crappily written
intro every day of the working week be
sure to subscribe so now here's what I
got a massive update has arrived for
watchdogs too so if you're actually
still playing which drugs to it sounds
like there's a lot to be excited about
Ubisoft has described to the 1.13 patch
as the game's biggest free updates so
far one of the most significant changes
is showdown the new 2v2 pvp mode
designed to be an endgame challenge that
you can play with a friend or a stranger
found through matchmaking matches are
set in 15 different locations and
involve one of three different objective
types that play out similarly to capture
the flag a king of the hill and
domination style modes drone motocross
and e kart racers all receive
multiplayer support with the new update
and the world is now peppered with armor
dilute trucks that you can hack to
activate a police hood mode that you'll
need to survive in order to gain the
aforementioned looked a 1.13 patch also
adds new clothing options a paintball
gun and general bug fixes and
improvements you can find out exactly
what's changed in our story on games
budge next up sony has published the top
20 best-selling games on PSN for March
taking the number one spot in this
jam-packed month was ubisoft's latest
objective marker Clara Ghost Recon
wildlands that breeze horizon it's the
past but really the future zero dawn
placed second with space Botox simulator
2017 Mass Effect Andromeda taking out
the third spot thanks to the revived
interest in Mass Effect the mass of X
trilogy tops the ps3 sales charts and
the god of war collection took out the
top spot on Vita usually this is where I
tell you to go to GameSpot's check out
the rest of the list but instead I'm
gonna read you out the entire list super
fast because Dan thought it would be
funny and didn't realize how annoying
this would be to edit let's go Ghost
Recon wildlands horizon zero dawn Mass
Effect Andromeda and they'll be the show
17 battlefield one god of war 3
remastered p for 17 in battlefield 4
rocket league grand theft auto 5 near
automata arcserve I
pack minecraft kingdom hearts HD 1.5
plus 2.5 remix fauna madden NFL 17
plants vs zombies garden warfare 2 call
judy infinite warfare NBA 2k 17 @ batman
arkham knight finally it sounds like
star wars battlefront 2 will not have a
DLC season pass creative director Byrne
steamer told mashable we don't have a
season pass so you know that was the
first thing that tipped us off he added
I cannot talk about the specifics of
this but we have something different in
mind that will allow you to play longer
be more invested in the game without
having a fragmented community that
fragmented community Dima is referring
to is related to the issues that arose
with 2015 battlefront where players who
didn't only extra content couldn't play
with the full community of players
making it difficult to find a match on
this Deemer said the community is
falling apart because they are simply
not many people playing the different
modes he explained when we looked at the
way battlefront had evolved over its
lifetime with the DLC and everything we
decided you know what for this type of
game season passes are not the best
thing that is everything I got for you
today do let me know what you thought of
today's stories down in that comment
section head to gamespot for all the
latest news and creatures and i will see
you again tomorrow